foreign
difference in DNA between humans and
chimps yet we like to think of ourselves
as highly Superior highly Superior
intellectually to the chimp right maybe
the difference in our brain power is as
small as that one percent indicates so
that pulling termites out of a mound
with a stick that was carefully chosen
from a branch right is from a from a
bush maybe that is not very far from
space travel the Hubble telescope right
think about it I know this sounds crazy
no no think about it maybe maybe look at
those cute little humans in their
television that's what they're saying up
there look at that is that a space
shuttle that they just launched okay so
now watch the smartest chimp yeah that
are studied in Labs right that are
brought in forth in the chimp societies
right you bring them forward and what do
they do they'll stack boxes to reach a
banana they might put up an umbrella
they'll do some things okay have
rudimentary assignment our toddlers can
do that right but those are the smartest
chimps okay
if the smartest chimp equals our toddler
and there's only one percent difference
in DNA between us right let's go one
percent Beyond us
oh
that's scary that's what I'm saying if
we go one percent Beyond Us in that same
Vector of intelligence yeah they're
traveling at the speed of light then
they've they've got light travel then
the smartest human
they'll roll forward they'll take
they'll take Stephen Hawking and they'll
say this human is slightly smarter than
the rest because he can do astrophysics
calculations in his head right like
little Timmy over here who just came
home from Alien preschool right
the toddler the toddler right
and he said oh you just compose a sonnet
isn't it cute let's put it up on the
refrigerator oh you just derived the
principles of calculus oh this is that
cute that's funny so if so if the
smartest human does what their toddlers
can do right their average people will
have thoughts they will have sentences
that will rise above and beyond
our most brilliant capacity to
understand and I stay awake at night
wondering whether the universe has
complexities in it that are Out Of Reach
of the neurosynapses of the human brain
wow that's my answer so there's
information out there that we just
cannot conceive or personally we don't
even know how to ask how to access that
right about it to get an answer correct
we don't know the answer we don't know
the question to get an answer to get an
answer right and not that we don't know
it because we haven't been told it yet
no we just can't conceive it can't
conceive it you go to a chimp and say go
to a chimp and say
um
uh what would it be oh something as
simple as navigating the Stars to get
someplace right you can't do that stars
what what navigate what right what
spaceship what rocket fuel what none of
that none of it you can't even have that
conversation right so that's my point
now I'm thinking that that whole thing
might be some type of like
science experiment by some alien kid now
this why not wanna
we are all a simulation in an alien
kid's basement who hasn't moved out of
the house yet that's so funny
we're the Minecraft of some other yeah
Minecraft
yes wow wow that yeah yeah and then when
things get too peaceful and stable
they stir the pot they throw in a
politician a war a crazy person throwing
things and then oh now it's entertaining
so it was just entertainment for this is
the best video game
okay uh
wow wow that's a well listen that's a
great answer to what boggles your mind
that's a really yeah it does so much
Boggle my mind it upsets my mind yeah I
was about to say it's very upsetting are
we not I'm mad I don't even know why
like here's my one out you're right go
ahead because
for humans our knowledge is cumulative
so true you don't have to invent
calculus somebody else did that right
you just have to you could use it right
learn it and use it right so I have the
feeling that we are every Next
Generation that has sort of brilliant
people contributing to our understanding
of the universe they're adding our rung
to a ladder right and then we all sort
of climb up down and then just get that
next round
next round well with that in mind I
think that the next
um evolutionary step for human beings is
that we will create an intelligence
greater than our own
that's really the deal this scares the
hell out of everyone yeah because that
intelligence will say we don't need you
at you know what and we'd have to say
you're right that's what happened in The
Matrix
how long do you think the human race
will actually survive
wow I mean there's precedent for that
right well so that you can look at what
is the average life expectancy mammal
species exactly and last I checked it
was around two million years or
something like that and so we've been
around a long way to go we have a long
way to go we've been around you know a
couple hundred thousand years in our in
our current anatomical form Cro-Magnon
form right and so that means we have a
long way to go but this presumes that
the species is not smart enough to kill
itself well then it's over
it was nice to know you guys yeah we
have invented multiple ways to kill
ourselves yeah and I don't think the
elephants did or you know nobody else
did this right uh the mice no they're
not killing themselves right humans yes
where the as the Buddhist monks call it
the so-called monkey brain
that causes us to do so much destructive
um work to each other and to the planet
will we ever get to a place where we
overcome that or we're able to train
those who come behind us to overcome
that okay now it does happen in some
so if we follow the reasoning by Stephen
Pinker in his book The Better angels of
our nature he studied the likelihood of
you dying before maturity or dying
before adulthood we're just dying
from at the hands of another human
from early days of tribal Warfare to
Modern days of
of State sanctioned
Global Warfare and what he found is that
the likelihood of you dying in that way
has been dropping ever since okay so
tribal Warfare you could you would kill
maybe a third or half of the other tribe
and or the entire tribe and then you win
and you get their land that doesn't
happen today
true the state surrenders
before that happened true saving the
lives of the rest of the population if
you look at I did this just recently if
you look at what countries had the
greatest percent of their population die
in the Second World War
I thought was it Belarus one of them is
very high it's like a third all right I
forgot the exact numbers but they're
high but they're not a half and you keep
going down and you get to to even combat
Germany even once they were heavily
bombed Germany Japan a fraction of the
total population
that is not how it used to end in tribal
Warfare
so
now consider that even so during the
second world war between 1939 and 1945 1
000 humans were killed by other humans
per hour
for every hour from 1939 to 1945
wow is that going on today no no no
although we're really slipping no stop
so we really got to pick up our game
just so we can yeah so the point is is
the greatest Generation the one where
the fewest fraction of everyone dies
out of hate we might have a lot of hate
but if the number of people who die from
it is lower than ever before right then
this Arc that you were hinting at that
may be a next Generation learns from the
previous one maybe that's gonna work
based on all your experiences and
knowledge thus far
he says based on all of your experiences
and knowledge thus far
what do you think the meaning of our
human existence is he just asks you what
is the meaning of life according to Neil
deGrasse Tyson okay so many people
are in search of the meaning of life as
though
it's behind a tree right under a rock
right if you are looking for meaning
you may never find it oh
so instead
recognize that you have the power to
manufacture meaning
create it within yourself
that's what I do
my meaning
for life is derived by several simple
principles
have I lessened the sufferings of others
today
that brings meaning to me
because that means the world is a little
better off because I was in it today
okay
if after your day is over the world is
worse off
you have subtracted meaning I should
kill myself
at the end of every day somebody is like
that
but go ahead so less than the suffering
of others in some way right it doesn't
mean redirect your whole life mind body
and soul but if you can help someone
across the street help an aging person
do you know make a little child last
just put a little bit of joy in the
world to lessen the suffering I also try
to learn something every day all right
now I'm a I I like being a Perpetual
student right most people hated being
students this saddens me
school's finished and what do you do you
run down the steps school is out forever
right throughout for the summer that
attitude captured in that song
is as though you don't want to be in
school and what's your only job in
school is to learn to learn and somehow
that's a chore yeah I don't blame you
for feeling that way I blame yourself
yeah for not instilling within us
Eternal curiosity knowing that you'll
spend more years of your life not in
school than in school and so if you have
curiosity you can be a lifelong learner
that's right and so I want to lessen the
sufferings of others and make sure I
learned something more about the world
today than I did yesterday nice and
who's to say whether that extra
increment of learning
can help me be better at blessing this
lessening the sufferings of others oh
so that is how I make meaning in life
and as a result I own thousands of books
thousands
and I read a little bit you know I have
a little stash near my bed and I cycle
them out
um and every day I try to it's harder
now because I get recognized
um but I try to help people every day
total stranger that's nice yeah so you
can make meaning for yourself look for
it because you may never find it the
vacuum
of space yes how exactly is it a vacuum
very nice that's a really good question
right okay when I was a kid a vacuum was
a physical object yes it was when I
heard physicists speak of the vacuum of
space I just imagine all these Hoovers
right in in the sky right so I didn't
know that a vacuum was a thing was it
was an it was a concept and then you
make a machine that duplicates that
thing I just didn't know that until I
learned okay so a vacuum is where
there's basically no air
okay you can have objects there but when
we think of a vacuum it's not a place
where there isn't anything it's a place
where there's no air molecules moving
typically all right generally you can
have some and we would still classify it
as a vacuum
does you have to distinguish like a
regular old vacuum or a perfect vacuum
right now you know what happens if
there's an object and you take away all
the air molecules
object out gases
their their air molecules embedded in
the surface of that object and they
start coming out it's fasten then you
can heat it it sends out more it's very
hard to make a perfect vacuum very hard
so
here's an old saying
nature
abhores abhor is a vacuum these are
people who've never been into space most
of the universe is a vacuum nature loves
a vacuum nice the point is when there's
a source of gravity all the air wants to
go to that source of gravity then it
leaves a vacuum everywhere else so a
vacuum is simply where there's no air
and it's not anything deep the odd thing
in the universe is that you have places
where where gas molecules collect okay
those are the unusual places in the
universe and they're called stars and
gaseous planets and the atmospheres of
rocky planets nice yeah so there you
have a vacuum lightning round how far
behind do you think astronomy would be
if the Earth didn't have a moon
wow okay so it's not how far behind we'd
be right it's how far Advanced we'd be
[Music]
um
okay so let me split this out yeah I
tweeted uh during Space Week the 50th
anniversary of the Apollo Landing
there's a saying that's common in the
space circles it's if God wanted us to
explore space
he would have given us a moon
right okay
so it's a good thing that's a good
saying yeah but that exploration is not
astrophysicists exploration that one is
people going into space right you build
a rocket to go where you don't have a
moon to visit all right if you talk
about astrophysics
do you know how many stars the naked eye
can see at night
more than I can count no it's not it's
about three to four thousand oh really
unaided yeah binoculars it's 100 times
that yeah telescopes is a billion times
that but all right three to four
thousand stars okay when it's a full
moon out
it's 300 Stars yeah right the moon
wreaks havoc on our ability yeah to see
the rest of the universe
so our observing schedules with huge
telescopes are split according to dark
time or bright time and if you look at
if you have bright time observations
it's the Moon is up and you can only
look at bright objects in the night sky
wow the Deep Universe only comes to us
when the moon is not up
so the Moon is basically a pain in the
ass it's a star blocker wow yes star
blocker look at that that's what it is
so astronomy would be
probably half again more advanced
because we would have had these greatest
telescopes in the world looking at the
night sky twice as often right in the
darkest parts of the night sky there you
go wow next that's a damn good answer
okay
um what if all the matter that we see in
the universe is just three-dimensional
part of some four-dimensional matter and
the dark gravity is just the Gravity
from the 4D part that we cannot see I
love it
we are so blind to a higher Dimension
right it could be that all the mysteries
in our three dimensions plus time are
completely solved by looking at this
stuff from a high from a higher
Dimension right right right just if you
lived in just a flat surface there'd be
stuff going on you had no idea right and
we say look can't you just see yeah just
look up right what is up what is that
giant graphite thing making making
making
creating stuff right on that flashlight
on that flat surface
where is he is mysterious it just shows
up right right right so I love it that's
the kind of universe I want it to be
because then when we figure out how to
see higher dimensions
foreign